-Our first guest is a four-time
Emmy-nominated actress for her
work on "Game of Thrones."
She's also --
-Whoo!
-Yeah! Oww!
She's also co-written
this new comic book called
"M.O.M. Mother of Madness."
The first issue came out today.
Here is Emilia Clarke!
Hey! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about!
Hey, bud!
-Hi!
-Emilia, it is so great
to see you.
I can't wait to talk about this.
I know we discussed it
maybe last time you were, like,
you were working on
or had this idea.
I know a lot of work
went into this.
-Yes.
-Congratulations. It's out.
Officially today.
-Thank you so much.
-Yeah.
-It's the strangest thing.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
-You've done a lot of cool
things since you've been here,
by the way.
You went skydiving.
-Yes.
-Which, uh...
Here's a photo of you
mid air skydiving.
Now -- Now what would
make you want to do this?
[ Laughter ]
You still look good
even skydiving.
Yeah, but I mean --
-You're lying.
-No, I'm not.
How did --
What made you want to do this?
-Okay. So basically,
this was for my birthday.
And I thought, "Okay.
I'm turning 34,"
which at that point,
now it's not scary,
but at the time, it was --
I couldn't even fathom the idea
that I would turn 34.
So, I thought I would do
something that was 10 times
scarier than turning 34, which
was jumping out of a plane.
-How was the person
strapped to you?
-Yeah.
-What's that all about?
And do you get
to interview them?
Do you know them before
they're strapped to you?
Do they talk to you?
-No.
-You don't know them?
-Okay.
So did you get, like, a --
Did you get a good pairing?
Did you get a wacky guy
or something?
I don't want a guy going like,
"3, 2..." and then
pulls the rip cord,
and you go...
You know, or does the thing like
"On the count of five.
5, 4..."
and then pulls the thing.
And you go --
That's not funny to me.
I don't know.
How was he?
-So, my mom and my brother
were the only people
who came with me.
And my mom is not 34.
And so I -- they get paired off
with their people.
And my mom gets, like,
Chipper Mick,
kind of Scouts guy who, like,
is, you know, all over it.
He's like the team leader.
-Yeah.
-My brother gets, like,
cool, serious guy,
who's taking it
really seriously.
-That's what I want.
-And I just get this guy
who's like "All right, luv,
let's go for it."
-Yeah, that's the crazy guy!
[ Laughter ]
That's who I would get.
-The crazy guy!
-The crazy guy who's like,
"Let's do it!
Oops!
I'm not strapped to you,
and I forgot the parachute,
dude!"
You know --
-That.
-You got that guy.
-Exactly.
-You landed, and you were so
happy or mad or something.
You just
couldn't stop screaming.
Look at you.
Just --
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah.
It was the biggest adrenaline
rush of my entire life.
Also, just for future reference,
if you're gonna jump
out of a plane, don't take
the two most important people
in the world to you, because
when you're sitting there,
my mom, first of all,
turns around to me
as the door opens
and just goes, "Yeah!"
[ Laughter ]
I love my mom.
-"I love you, Mom."
That's awesome.
That's so rad.
See? You'll never forget that.
I want to --
I want to talk about now also
the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
-Yes.
-You're now joining
the Marvel Universe
with this new --
with this new miniseries.
-Yes.
-What can we say?
Can we say the name of it or no?
-Well, okay.
So, yeah.
I'm pretty sure we can say
it's called "Secret Invasion."
-Okay.
-But I'm already scared.
The first people I spoke to from
Marvel were their security team.
And I am convinced
there is a man outside my house.
There's been a car parked there
for a long time.
And I swear to God,
he's undercover.
-Yeah, yeah.
But I think they're like,
"Well, you're also good
at keeping good secrets
for 'Game of Thrones,'
so, like, she's used to it."
-That's not -- that's what I
thought, but they schooled me.
And so --
I don't know what to do.
-All right, all right.
Well, congrats on that.
I want to talk about this
right here.
This is --
You co-wrote this.
A new comic book called
"M.O.M. Mother of Madness."
-Yes.
-How did it come about?
-Okay.
So it was just a silly idea.
It was a silly conversation
that happened in a car
on our way to a gig
with friends.
And we were like,
"Yeah, wouldn't it be funny
if there was a superhero
who wasn't perfect
and who was just
a big mess like us?"
And I was like,
"That would be really funny."
And, like, was anxious.
That would be really funny.
And then I went home
and just wrote that.
So I wrote like
50 pages of this,
and this kind of character
just came out of me.
And I did all the other
characters and just a lot of --
There was a lot of material
that was ready to come out.
And, uh --
And now it's here.
And it's real thing.
-I mean, it's great.
Do -- Do you meet with artists?
And how does it work?
-Yes. Yeah, yeah.
So now I know that there's
a lot of people that are
involved in making a comic.
There's like 11 people
that it takes to make a comic.
And I teamed up with
this incredible writer
called Marguerite Bennett,
who was my guru and my guide
'cause I didn't know the first
thing about making a comic.
And so I wrote all the stuff,
and then she turned it
into comic,
turned it into this thing.
-Yeah.
Yeah, comic form.
-This beautiful thing.
-It's gorgeous.
It's well-done.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-It's fantastic.
I mean, this is a big deal.
Do you think this could be
turned into a movie
or a TV show?
-Well, okay. So here's the way
I feel about this.
It's not why I started.
It's not why I made a comic.
I made a comic 'cause I'm crazy,
and so I did that.
And if it's really crap
and no one wants it,
then it won't be a movie.
-No, that's not true, no.
Please, we all know that you --
-If it's good...
-We all know how sane you are.
I mean -- yeah.
-There you go.
Yes.
-I think this thing
is fantastic.
You got to be really proud, bud.
Congratulations.
This is awesome.
-Thank you.
-Emilia Clarke.
"M.O.M. Mother of Madness"
is available now.
It is great.